-Welcome to the show.
I'm so happy to have you on.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
I'm so happy to be here.
-I've seen you at "SNL,"
I've seen you in the hallways,
but I've never had
you as a guest and I'm --
-And you've never said
a word to me.
-I know.
I like
to keep it really cool,
keep the mystique happening.
But, finally, you're here.
How's the week
going with Quinta?
-It's going great.
I think it's going to be
a really great show.
Quinta is so funny, so talented.
We had table read yesterday.
-Good.
-I think she's got it on lock.
-Yeah, yeah. Good.
And how about you?
Let's talk about you.
-Quinta is going to have
a really great show.
-Yeah.
-She's going to be amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it'll be fun for me.
I'll be in the show for sure.
We have a pretty big cast.
-Do you know,
when I was on the show,
when I was a featured player,
they had a rule that
if you weren't in the show,
they would take you
even out of the credits.
-That is messed up.
-So I would call my mom like,
"I'm not in the show at all.
Like I'm not even
in the credits."
-I hate that for you.
-Like, "Jimmy Fallon."
I wasn't even --
-Like, they skipped right to --
-No, they skipped
right over that.
-To the "G" last names?
-Exactly. Yeah. Completely.
It was rough.
-My mom called me
a few weeks ago
in the middle of the show
and was like,
"Hey, did you not
go to work tonight?
I don't see you."
-Oh, my God. It's rough.
It's rough, man.
-I said, "I'm here.
-"Yeah, I'm here.
I'm just not in the show
at all."
-But at least
I'm in the credits.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
At least you got the credits.
-Fooled her.
That's the thing about
it, though.
The credits -- if you're not
in the credits,
your mom knows
not to expect you in the show.
-Yeah. Then she's like, "This is
the best episode I ever saw."
You go, "Hey, I'm not in it."
Yeah.
I was talking to you backstage.
Because it was, like,
a kind of a sports-themed night.
We're talking about
March Madness.
And I said,
"Did you play any sports?"
You played a little basketball?
-I was going to say,
I played a little ballet.
Yes, I was a ballerina
for 10 years,
but I played
a little basketball.
I had a short-lived
basketball career.
-How short was it?
-It was three games.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-That counts.
-Exactly three games long.
So, I have to get this
off of my chest.
So, back in L.A.,
when I was coming up in improv,
there was this
all-female basketball league,
and a lot of the sketch
and improv players
were on this team
and on this league, right?
And it was highly coveted to be
in one of the teams, right?
But there were no spots.
There were never spots.
And it was like,
"Darn, you missed out."
So, a spot opened up,
and everyone was e-mailing,
being like,
"I want in, I want in."
I e-mailed.
I got a response immediately
that's like, "We want you."
And I have to believe
it's because I'm black.
I think they thought
I'd be good at basketball.
But here's the thing.
I also thought I'd be good
at basketball because I'm black.
Don't work that way.
It don't work that way.
-It doesn't work -- No.
-Turns out
it don't work that way.
-Do you know anything
about basketball?
-I know what traveling is.
-Oh, my gosh. Doesn't count.
-The very first game,
the other team,
I saw them sort of size
me up like,
"Oh, shoot,
The Traveling Pants have --"
That was our team name,
Traveling Pants.
But we weren't Traveling because
we know that's not allowed.
-Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah.
Good. You know that.
-So, the other team,
I saw them size me up like,
"Oh, shoot, they got a,
like, tallish black girl.
We're going to have to
look out for her," right?
First play happens.
I'm assuming
that's what it's called.
And I get out on the court.
This is real.
-"First play."
-Is that not what it's --
Tell me.
-No.
-Okay. Very cool. Alright.
I really don't know
what I'm talking about.
So, I get out on the court,
and the first whatever
it's called happens
and the ref starts screaming
at me to get out of the paint.
And I look at the court,
and I'm like,
"This whole thing is painted.
What is the paint?"
-There's nothing but paint.
Where do I go?
Am I traveling?
-Right. This is years later.
I still don't know
what the paint is.
-Okay.
-I don't know what
the paint is,
because, truly,
the whole thing is painted.
Or is that real wood?
-Yeah, no. Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-The paint is under the rim.
-Okay. Okay. Okay.
Because I've heard songs
like, "I go hard in the paint,"
and I was just like,
"Yeah, cool."
I didn't know what it meant.
But now I know.
Okay, it's under the rim.
So, anyway, I mean, people were
guarding me, like, arms up,
and my arms were up, too,
but mine meant like
"I surrender.
I am not a threat.
I'm not a threat."
I remember, like,
being wide open,
because everyone realized
very quickly,
I don't know what I'm doing.
-Yeah.
-"Actually, don't worry
about the black girl."
-No one was guarding you?
-Nobody was guarding me.
And my team --
my teammate had the ball
and needed to pass it
to someone,
and I was the only one
who was open.
Arms were still up,
and I was like, "Don't do that.
Please don't do that.
Please don't do that."
-Could I tell you about you're
having such a fantastic season
on "Saturday Night Live."
I think I told --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Really. Fantastic.
-Thank you.
-The sketch I remember I was
e-mailing a bunch of --
you know, Higgins and our
friends over at "SNL."
I said, "There's that sketch
last night,
'Lisa from Temecula,'"
where you were cutting --
you were cutting the steak
on the table,
and the table was shaking.
Dude, it was unbelievably funny.
It made me laugh out loud.
I go, "What is going on?"
I know those people
that kind of cut too much,
and the whole table
is shaking.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Walk me through it.
Did you -- Do you know
someone who did this?
-You know, I used to be
a Lisa from Temecula,
except for I was an
Ego from Baltimore.
I used to order my steaks
well-done.
I got bullied out of it.
People bullied me enough --
I stopped doing that.
But Alex English,
who wrote this sketch
alongside Gary Richardson,
another writer, and
Michael Che -- people know --
his cousin
is a Lisa from Temecula,
is not from Temecula.
I don't know if she knows
it's about her,
so I might have blown his cover.
-Wow! Wow! It's happening.
-But it is about his cousin,
who I guess he went to dinner
over one of our hiatuses,
and she had ordered her steak
well-done.
It was kind of
shaking the table.
Only thing is, no one said
anything to her about it.
So I guess this was cathartic
and healing for him.
-And did you know that
in dress rehearsal --
Like, sometimes, you go,
"Oh, I got a feeling
this is going to be
a fun, big sketch."
-Well, okay, so, all week long,
we had thought
it was going to be so exciting.
I mean, when we did it
at table read,
I couldn't -- They had a steak
delivered to me at table read,
and that doesn't happen.
And Mikey Day and I,
by the way, have this bit
where he -- I think it's a bit.
I hope it's a bit.
Where he thinks I'm a diva.
And someone delivered
a steak to me at our table read,
in the middle of our
table read, and he saw it.
Like, he saw it
and he was like, "What?!"
-"You really are a diva.
Wow! My God."
-Right, right. Truly.
So, the steak comes to me.
I'm doing it at table.
I can't get through
the sketch at table read
because I'm laughing so much.
And then, every time we run it,
I'm laughing
and can't really get through it.
And I thought, "How am I going
to do this for the air show?"
Well, at dress rehearsal,
it didn't go so well.
The table wasn't shaking.
I got a T-bone steak
all of a sudden.
Can't can't saw through
a T-Bone steak.
Not because it's well-done.
There's a bone in the middle.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, it was a --
Like, all week long,
everyone thought
it was going to go well.
But I have this
little theory that, like,
everyone thinking a sketch
is going to kill on Saturday
is like the kiss of death.
I'm like, If everyone
thinks it's going to kill,
it's going to tank.
And that did happen
at dress rehearsal.
But then -- I don't know --
Lorne had faith in it,
and he brought it --
-And it went to air, and, man,
that was the best sketch
of the year.
Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you.
-That was unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Thank you
for coming on the show.
Have a great show this weekend.
Ego Nwodim.
"Saturday Night Live"
returns this weekend
on NBC
and Peacock the next day,
with host Quinta Brunson
and musical guest Lil Yachty.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.